problem to me isn't freaking increasing
the age the problem to me is we are no
longer selling the values and principles
that made America such a great country
where people around the world wanted to
come and raise their families here
that's the permanent problem Adam and I
think that's what we're having issues
with when's the last time you saw
somebody like even when's the last time
you saw somebody on Fox or or MSNBC or
CNN just praying
what was the last time you say hey I
just want to do a prayer can we do a
prayer here's what I want to pray and
you pray for peace you pray for
forgiveness you pray for you know
improving you pray for love you pray you
I again I know this is boring stuff
none of us wanted to hear this stuff
from our parents when we were kids none
of us wanted to hear it but guess what
those who did benefited from it those
who didn't didn't benefit from it so
that's what I'm saying where I'm not
looking for like hey let's just pass
it's only gonna affect five percent